well so whenever you encounter some
sudden danger out there in the world
that the information from that stimulus
let's say it's a snake on the path will
go into your brain through the visual
system if it's a visual stimulus and
then will rise through the visual system
through the standard pathways so every
sensory system has this very
well-organized set of circuits that
ultimately leads to a stop in a part of
the brain called the thalamus on route 2
reaching the sensory cortex
so each sensory system has an area in
the cortex the cortex is that wrinkled
part of the brain that you see whenever
we see a picture of the brain and that's
where we have our perceptions and
thoughts and all of that so in order to
have a visual perception information has
to be transmitted from the eye from the
retina through the optic nerve into the
visual thalamus and from the visual
thalamus to the visual cortex where the
processing continues and you then
ultimately have the perception so the
visual cortex connects directly with the
amygdala and so that's one route by
which the information can get in retina
thalamus cortex amygdala but one of the
first things that I discovered when I
started studying fear was that that rat
that pathway the usual pathway that we
think about for sensory processing was
not the way that fear was elicited or
not the only way what we found was that
if the cortical pathway was was blocked
completely rats could still form a
memory about a sound we were studying
sounds and shocks but we've also done it
with the visual stimuli so the what we
found was that sound had to go up to the
level of the thalamus but then it didn't
need to go to the auditory cortex or the
visual cortex if it was a visual
stimulus instead it made a an exit from
the sensory system and went directly
into the amygdala below the level of the
cortex that was really important because
we generally think that the cortex is
required for any kind of conscious
experience so this is a way that
information was being sent through the
brain and triggering emotions
unconsciously so the psycho animal
love this it was it because it
vindicates the idea that you could have
this unconscious fear that the cortex
has no understanding of so the the idea
was elaborated a bit into this concept
where these patents it's possible that
the cortical and the thalamic inputs to
the amygdala could become dissociated in
people for one reason or another such
that the stimuli that are triggering the
amygdala from the thalamus wouldn't
necessarily match those that the cortex
is attending to so in order to again to
consciously attend to a stimulus you
need the cortex so let's say we're
having lunch one day and it's a red and
white checkered tablecloth and we have
this argument and then the next day I
see somebody coming down the street
that's saying I have this gut feeling
about this guy he's an sob I don't like
him and maybe what's going on there he
says he's got a red and white checkered
necktie on consciously I'm saying it's
you know my gut feeling because I don't
like the way he looks but what's
happened is that the necktie has
triggered the activation of the amygdala
through the thalamus the lope the so
called low-road triggered a fear
response in me which I now consciously
interpret as this gut feeling about not
liking the guy but in fact it's being
triggered by external stimuli that I'm
not processing consciously so this this
is important because a lot of people
have fears and phobias and anxieties
about things they don't understand they
don't know why they're afraid or anxious
in a particular time it may be through
various kinds of experiences the low
road gets potentiated in a way that it's
activating fears and phobias outside of
conscious awareness and that doesn't
make sense in terms of what the
conscious brain is looking at in the
world or hearing in the world because
they've been separately parsed out so
the subcortical pathway we've been able
to time all this very precisely in the
rat brain
it takes an order for a sound to get to
the amygdala from the subcortical
pathway takes about ten or twelve
milliseconds so take a second divide
into a thousand parts and after twelve
of those little parts the amygdala is
already getting the sound consciously it
you know for you to be consciously aware
of a stimulus it takes 250 300
milliseconds so the amygdala is being
triggered much much faster than
consciousness is processing so the brain
ticks in milliseconds the neurons
process information on the level of
milliseconds but the mind is processing
things on the order of seconds and half
seconds you know so if you have a fear
response that's being triggered very
rapidly like that consciously you're
going to be interpreting what's going on
but it's not going to necessarily match
what's really going on